THE RULES COMMITTEE FOR
THURSDAY MAY THIRD.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN IS HEREBY COLD
ORDER. PLEASE REVISE AND AUDIO
AND VIDEO RECORDING OF TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS BEING MADE. HAS ALSO
BEEN TELEVISED. OF MANAGE
SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL COOLEY.
HERE CUNNINGHAM.
HERE CARILLO YEAH.
SO ROTTEN HERE FRIEDMAN
GALLAGHER.
GRAYSON MAYES
THOSE AREA PRESIDENT SOLID CMOS
AND.
WALDRON.
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
WE HAVE CONSENT AGENDA IS OUR.
AND CHILDREN SECOND MOVER MISTER
CELIS SECONDED BY MS CERVANTES.
AMOUNT OF SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I.
CARILLO AYE CARILLO AYE
CERVANTES AYE CHAU ROTH HAS AYE
FRIEDMAN GALLAGHER. GRAYSON
MAYES HAS AREA.
FIVE NAZARIAN AYE SOLID SIDE
FOLLOWS AYE WALDRON.
THE MOTION PASSES AND THE